temperatures are are cooling across
Europe setting the continent in a Race
Against Time utilities are rushing to
forge new long-term gas delivery
contracts and build critical
infrastructure now that Russia has
slashed pipeline exports to the EU
Germany like many of its neighbors is
turning to shipments of liquefied
natural gas or LNG to fill much of the
need on Tuesday its efforts took another
step forward
construction on a new 40 kilometer
pipeline is set to begin at this
facility in Lube mean this pipeline will
be in the middle of the Baltic Sea it's
a key piece of infrastructure to get LNG
off of ships via future terminal and
sent to the rest of Germany Lube mean
will be Germany's second LNG terminal
its first is in wilhelmshofen it's
anticipated to go online this winter
the project will open the doors for
liquefied natural gas to be delivered
through existing Networks
Germany's climate and economy Minister
Robert habbeck toured the site which is
expected to start delivering about 4.5
billion cubic meters of gas per year
starting in 2023.
the aim is to get gas elsewhere and then
to import it into the country this
import is what is Germany's biggest
problem as mentioned we have the
possibility to buy gas but we don't have
the infrastructure to import it apart
from lubeen and nordstream one we are
working at high pressure to create this
infrastructure so that we can import
this gas
finding new sources of gas is critical
to the German economy that's because
there's currently no gas flowing through
the Nordstrom one pipeline which once
carried 59 billion cubic meters of gas
to Europe each year
if everything works well and if Germany
can manage to live frugally and if we
are lucky with the weather we have the
chance to get through winter
something I would not have said just a
few months ago we have a chance
Chancellor Olaf Schultz is expected to
sign contracts for liquefied natural gas
during his visit to the United Arab
Emirates this weekend
lomon is With the Energy Information
service inner gate he focuses on natural
gas Aiko thanks for coming on to the
show I want to begin today with the news
that German gas reserves have reached
more than 90 percent full how important
is that milestone for getting this
country through the winter
we have enough yes in the storage but of
course it's not the whole story it makes
it a bit more confident that we can
weather in particular times of cold
weather but nevertheless we need
um it will be important to have first
energy from the beginning of next year
and it will be important that we safely
I guess over the winter in particular
when it becomes a colder one
okay we just heard a little bit about
this LNG terminal construction beginning
on its on the on the on the Baltic Sea
um but are utilities here any closer to
signing deals for regular LNG deliveries
right now they've just been buying on
the spot Market
yeah I think that's that's of course a
bit the critical issue it's it's um
there there have been some some
medium-term contracts smaller contracts
that had recently be signed the
universider contract are they signed a
contract that means the bid is going on
but uh what will be happening over the
winter that what the the companies are
promising that they will guess will
deliver gas from their existing
portfolio and what I have of course but
I'm up to then be honest I'm a bit a
little bit scared that was probably what
happened that it will shift simply
deliberatives from terminals in Belgium
and Netherlands to the German to the
German uh General that may will not help
really Europe and the balance
Utilities in Germany are in negotiations
with Qatar for example about LNG
deliveries is any deal likely to be in
Germany's favor if Qatar has been
insisting on long-term agreements I
think 25 years has been the talk at
least at the beginning
yeah that's I think I think that's one
of the groups of one of the crucial
issues it's for German utilities uh
duration of 20 to 25 years will will be
hard to swallow because
um basically during a real face out
natural gas and that does not really fit
with these young kind of long-term
contracts we really have to see how this
will at the end of the day was that how
that will be balanced and perhaps one
word to Mr Schultz who is going now to
the United error Arabs and to Saudi
Arabia Capital this weekend at the end
of the day that is what as you said the
utilities have to sign contracts and I
think political politics May support but
will not at the end of the day sign
contracts
it's also been said that of course
Energy savings will play a major role in
getting the country through the winter
from your perspective our households and
businesses poised to cut back enough uh
in the amount needed for this winter
and again it depends on the on the
weather I think what you see already is
some some decent reduction in in deaths
of industrial demand quality is simply
demand destruction due to to weak to the
weak economy part is switching to other
fuels also it's a bit difficult to see
but in principle the very very high
prices should give an incentives such a
safe um gas for ourselves and whether it
will be enough or not and I will be seen
at the end of the winter all right haiko
Loma and focuses on natural gas for the
information service inner gate thank you
okay thank you very much well let's
discuss Germany's approach to its gas
crisis further we're joined by Emily
McLean she's an analyst in the natural
gas Market at reisterstad energy thanks
a lot for being with us Emily how do you
assess uh the the pace of Germany's
shift to LNG because things seem to be
moving quite fast
yes you're correct they are moving fast
and Germany is really at the center of
the race or at the front of the race if
you will
um really since the beginning of the
Russian invasion we've seen more than 20
new LNG import terminals being proposed
that's in Europe
um of that almost a third of those
projects are in Germany so about 31
percent
uh now the uh wilhelms often fsru that's
about seven and a half million tons that
project's still under construction uh
but its first fsru is on track to start
later this year and that'll add uh you
know incremental capacity to to
germinate
yeah the key thing there is that it can
come in the winter at least if not to
help with the winter itself so how far
can the LNG actually go towards you know
fulfilling Germany's natural gas Shuffle
because LNG has to be transported
transported obviously by boat it can't
be sent you know by the the you know the
the billion barrels uh down a pipeline
so can Germany rely on LNG as an
alternative
so to answer that question yes uh
absolutely Germany can rely on LNG and
it will have to the country will have to
going forward not just this year but in
the coming years
um I would say you'd have to start with
looking back at last year looking back
at this year and really just seeing how
Germany has imported its gas uh in the
past so this past year in 2021 we were
looking around 48 50 BCM of piped gas
now that's not including at LNG and
that's really made up about 50 percent
of Germany's gas Imports of that about
12 to 13 percent are coming from Russia
pipe gas alone
so Germany's still bringing in piped gas
from the non-russian sources those are
holding steady but what we've really
seen in terms of the changes in the
landscape and imports this year is that
additional LNG Imports that have really
been a requirement to meet demand needs
this year
but to your question even with LNG
Imports and with the steady flows of
non-russian gas Imports really the
country can't reach those uh reached a
level that would completely offset
Russian gas they have managed to reach
very high storage levels now so roughly
80 89 percent as of last week and they
may also reach their November storage
Target of 95 ahead of schedule and
that's all because of LNG
okay Emily McLean from right side energy
thank you very much for bringing us your
insights here on DW business